bléré et son canton 350 kilomètres
carrés d'un paysage qui nous semble
connue ordinaire et qui pourtant recèle
des trésors patrimoniaux inconnu
martinez chercheur
elle travaille sur l'inventaire du
patrimoine culturel qu'il soit privé au
public depuis huit ans el khadri le
canton carte ign à la main notre formule
choc pour définir c'est que on
inventorie de la petite cuillère à la
cathédrale
donc ça signifie qu'on prend en compte
les objets mobiliers et l' architecture
et pas seulement l'oeuvre d'art mais
ceux qui feignent patrimoine donc il
peut évidemment s'agir d'oeuvres d'art
il peut s'agir dob de série et peut
s'agir de bâtiments qui ont une
particularité est qu'ils prennent sens
d'après le contexte dans lequel ils sont
construits diplôme d'histoire de l'art à
l'école du louvre dea de préhistoire de
muséologie martin est armé pour un
travail de repérage et d' analyse
aujourd'hui elle recherche à bléré tout
bâtiment
un intérêt culturel particulier
construit entre le cinquième et le 20e
siècle
mon travail consiste à comparer le
cadastre anciens le cadastre actuelle et
à voir quels sont les bâtiments qui ont
pu être modifiée les bâtiments qui ont
disparu parfois il s'agit du lot entier
curieuse passionnés martin explore
quartier par quartier maison par maison
sans a priori mais le travail de
repérage n'est pas simple les
ravalements fait au cours du temps
perturbe la datation du bâti et puis
parfois au détour d'une rue un trésor se
dévoile mois attiré mon attention
puisque on le voit de l'extérieur en
fait c'est le décor sculpté convoi sous
cette tour qui est tout à fait
exceptionnel qui est un décor première
renaissance puisque le logis c'est
logique boisramé 1 et qui a appartenu en
fait un officier d'artillerie de
françois 1er et on peut dater la
construction de ce logis des environs de
526 128
il faut prendre le temps d'expliquer la
démarche parce que ça n'a rien d'évident
de laisser entrer quelqu'un d'inconnu
chez soi donc tout à fait normal mais en
général en touraine j'ai eu l'occasion
de constater que les gens sont férus de
patrimoine les gens connaissent la
patrimoine souvent apprécié et ils ont à
coeur de préserver notre travail est une
entreprise de connaissance du patrimoine
et il n'y a pas de prescription qui sont
liées à ce travail de connaissance
après la ville la campagne l'inventaire
prévoit de s'intéresser aux fermes loge
de vignes l'avoir puis four à chaux et
moulins et justement cachée de regard
sur les rives du cher
le moulin fort construit en 15/100 dans
l'histoire est liée à celle de
chenonceau alors ça c'est un bâtiment
tout à fait exceptionnel parce que
retrouver un moulin dans le lit du cher
qui datent d'une époque en fin du xvième
siècle c'est quand même quelque chose de
tout à fait peu ordinaire les
aménagements sont conservés l'escalier
de l'est certes qui permettait d'accéder
à l'étagé le ponton sur lequel on
pouvait décharger et les piles sont en
excellente état on s'intéresse à tous
types de patrimoines des bâtiments comme
ça mais aussi des bâtiments beaucoup
plus modeste pour ceux qui sont liés à
l'eau par exemple on va s'intéresser au
lavoir
on peut s'intéresser aux fontaines et
même certains types de pompes anciennes
donc voyez c'est quand même assez vaste
5000 photos 200 dossiers d'édifices 400
d'objets religieux
voilà en partie le résultat des
recherches de martine bientôt
consultables conseil régional est
répertoriée sur le plan national lancé
par andré malraux en 1964 couvrant
aujourd'hui un tiers du territoire
national
l'inventaire permet d'enrichir la
connaissance de notre paysage culturel
et architectural pour décider de son
avenir ensemble
moment